Now I'm going to show you the solution to the search problem
rather than try to make you do it yourself,
because there are still a few tricks here that are different from the previous search problem.
I'm going to define problem, which takes a sequence of elements here.
If you want, you can pass in a frozen set of  or whatever,
but if you didn't I'm going to go ahead and do that kind of version for you.
I'm going to make it into a frozen set, and I'm going to add in the light
in case you forgot to specify that.
You can just ask bridge_problem of the list 1, 2, 5, 10. I'll take care of it all for you.
Like before, the explored set starts off being the empty set.
The frontier starts off being the one initial state,
which is the frozen set we just made up for everything that's on the here side,
and empty set for everything that's on the there side, and 0 for the elapsed time.
The idea is to get everybody away from here onto the other side.
If we were given a trival problem where there was already nobody here,
then we're done and we return that initial state.
Otherwise, just like before, we start popping things off the frontier.
Just like before we're looking at our successors,
and the only difference is down here.
Whereas before we put a path on the end, and we were expanding our our frontier
and taking off the shortest path first from our frontier,
because in the previous problem, in the water-pouring problem,
the best solution was to find as the solution that was shortest, with the smallest number of steps.
In this problem, the best solution is defined as the one with the smallest elapsed time
where the elapsed time of a path is the second element.
That's the t element here of the final element of the path.
That would be the total elapsed time of a path.
So we sort the frontier by the total elapsed time.
Now it is a little bit wasteful here that we're going through this loop,
we only added in one new element, and we sorted the whole thing.
Python's actually pretty good at that type of sort.
There are other ways to make that more efficient,
but just conceptually that's what we're doing.
We always want to have the frontier sorted, so that we're taking the fastest time first.
I typed that program in, and I ran it for the very first time.
Bridge_problem([1, 2, 5, 10]).
I got an answer back.
Remember, the answer is a path, which is an alternation of states and actions.
We can pick out just the actions, like this,
by asking for the path and then taking a slice of that path,
starting at element number 1, going to the end,
and giving us every other element.
That'll be just the actions.
Those are these three actions.
That's my proposed solution that my program came up with.
My question is is that correct? Yes or no?